say you go in
three to six months you fully prepare to
fight okay
and say there is a fight with you
against conor or against khabib
those two names if a fight was with you
against conor at their age today and say
khabibo green and said he wants to come
back we know it's not going to happen he
said he's not going to do because when
his father died he promises mom that
he's not going to come back and you're
saying 100 you're not going to do it
even for 30 million dollars you said you
would do 400 million dollars right now
for no no no no but but if if it did and
you did train we know it's not going to
happen but if it did do you think you
could beat a conor or a khabib today if
you did go six months training and they
did as well well if i have the the the
same the motivation to do it yeah i
believe so even at this age do you think
you can be like
if i have the motivation to go to
another area and you don't want to do it
no i don't want to do it i i don't want
to have the heart i don't want to have
the
motivation